continúa la información en france 24 y
hablamos ahora de economía estamos para
eso con danger hablando aunque nos va a
contar lo más importante de esta jornada
ni la bienvenida
empezamos en chile porque se preparan
para discutir un tercer retiro de
pensiones para el día na buenas noches
mire el congreso chileno está en este
momento de vacaciones pero una vez él
regrese en marzo tiene prevista la
discusión de un proyecto de origen
opositor para un nuevo retiro de un 10%
de los fondos que tienen los ciudadanos
en las cuentas de ahorro individual este
sería el tercero en menos de un año en
julio de 2020 recordemos se aprobó un
primer retiro que disfrutaron 10 de los
11 millones de afiliados y en diciembre
del mismo gobierno sacó adelante otro
proyecto similar al que se acogieron más
de 7 millones pero hoy el gobierno
advierte que esta vez se va a oponer
argumenta que ya se han entregado más de
34 mil millones de dólares y que hasta
hoy casi 3 millones de ciudadanos ya se
quedaron sin ahorros pensionales daniela
y en eeuu los propietarios de vivienda
tendrán más
para ponerse al día con sus presas si
liliana la pandemia del cob y de 19
tiene hoy en ese país a uno de cada
cinco inquilinos atrasados con el
alquiler y poco más de 10 millones de
propietarios no están al día con el pago
de su hipoteca esto equivale casi al 12%
el programa de alivio para estas
personas ya no irá hasta el 31 de marzo
sino hasta el 30 de junio y consiste
básicamente en que los propietarios
pueden congelar sus préstamos bancarios
y se prohíben además las ejecución las
ejecuciones hipotecarias también
conocidas como desalojos o desahucios
hasta ese entonces pero el decreto
firmado este martes incluye sólo a los
propietarios más no a los inquilinos
atrasados con el pago de la renta
daniela y el precio del byt coi superó
por primera vez en su historia los 250
mil dólares cuéntenos pues dirían
hagamos un repaso mire en sus inicios en
2009 la primera moneda descentralizada
es decir que no cuenta con la vigilancia
de instituciones monetarias costaba
apenas 60 voz de dólar ya en 2013 su
valor superó los 1.000
y comenzó a llamar la atención tras
varios altibajos y caracterizada siempre
por una gran volatilidad es imparable
cripto divisa es hoy cinco veces más
costosa de lo que era hace un año el
martes se cotizó por encima de los 50
mil dólares para cerrar un poco por
debajo de ese valor la razon liliana es
que ha venido ganando aceptación
generalizada como medio de pago
después de que tesla anunciara que va a
recibir bitcoins en parte de pago de sus
autos de lujo el new york-mellon que es
el antiguo o el banco más antiguo de
eeuu dijo que lo incluirá en su
portafolio también lo hizo más cerca y
antes lo había hecho paypal
pero aunque el mundo se está volcando
hacia este tipo de inversión las
autoridades se siguen advirtiendo de sus
riesgos de sus riesgos porque al momento
que ocurre algo con esto pues no hay a
quien reclamarle bueno daniela gervais
exit afectó la industria creativa
británica desde que reino unido se
separó oficialmente de la unión europea
el pasado 31 de diciembre los ciudadanos
británicos ya no pueden vivir ni
trabajar libremente por los 27 países
comunitario equity que es el sindicato
de los principales actores británicos
advirtió que esto representa un daño
irreparable para su negocio pues ahora
tienen que tramitar visas para ellos y
para sus equipos en una carta para dar
un script firmada por un centenar de
actores dicen que los altos costos y la
burocracia les hace imposible actuar en
estos países el mes pasado también hubo
una misiva similar firmada por unos 100
músicos y aunque todos piden negociar
los términos del acuerdo de salida pues
el gobierno dice que eso no se puede
hacer pero si va a buscar acuerdos
bilaterales con algunos países daniel en
cuéntanos cuáles son los indicadores de
la jornada wall street' del cerro
generalmente a la baja pero su principal
índice el dow jones de industriales-
marcó un nuevo récord
las bolsas europeas bajaron después de
conocerse que la eurozona se contrajo en
68 por ciento en 2020 en américa latina'
resultados mixtos con un repunte
destacable en la bolsa mexicana nadie la
cifra del día 1.200 millones de dólares
liliana eso es lo que estiman los
analistas que pueden
la estadounidense reebok una filial de
adidas que esta firma alemana va a sacar
a la venta porque no cumplió con las
expectativas esto es apenas una tercera
parte de lo que le costó en 2006 en ese
momento pagó 3 mil 800 millones de
dólares para hacerle competencia a su
archirrival nike nació daniela por la
información de economía y de ustedes
gracias continúen con más central 24
punto com
[Música]